لما يقرب من أربعة أشهر ،
تم إغلاق متحف لويزفيل بالكامل اليوم ،
وأعيد فتح أبوابه أخيرًا ليس
للعمل كالمعتاد لأنه في يوم عادي
، سيستقبل متحف اللوفر من 30 إلى
40.000 سائح 75 ٪ منهم من الخارج
اليوم لإعادة افتتاحه الكبير كان هناك
فقط  7400 زائر نتيجة
حقيقة أن المتحف اضطر إلى وضع
نظام خاص حيث كان عليك
الحجز والدفع المسبق للدخول عبر الإنترنت أيضًا
في الداخل للتأكد من
عدم وجود حشد كبير جدًا أمام
أي من الأعمال  في المتحف
، تم وضع نظام خاص أحادي الاتجاه
لمراقبة تدفق حركة المرور مما يعني أن
هذا كان حقًا الوقت المثالي
للحضور وإمتاع عينيك بأعمال مثل
الموناليزا وعلامة أخرى على أن فرنسا
تعود ببطء إلى شيء ما  مثل
ما كان عليه الأمر في
الوقت الذي تعمل فيه إسبانيا بشكل كبير ،
عاد بعض العلماء
هناك بصب الماء البارد على ما
يسمى بنظرية مناعة القطيع ، حيث
أجروا ما يبدو أنه أكبر
دراسة في هذا المجال.  الموضوع في أوروبا
واستنتاجهم حول تحقيق مناعة القطيع
مع kovat 19 لا تعول عليه.
al Goodman موجود في مدريد مع المزيد
، فلنبدأ في تلك الدراسة ، ماذا يمكنك أن
تخبرنا عنها
مرحباً Kim حسنًا ، كان هذا 61 ألف
مشارك  في جميع أنحاء البلاد ، قالت
عينة تمثيلية من السلطات الإسبانية
إن 5 ٪ فقط لديهم
أجسام مضادة للفيروس التاجي ، وهذا يعني أن
هناك بعض الاتصال بالفيروس ، وهذا
يعني نظريًا بعض المناعة ، لكن هذا
يعني أيضًا أن 95 ٪ لم يكن لديهم أي
اتصال ، لذا فإن الدراسة الإسبانية التي  تم
نشره في المجلة الطبية المرموقة
The Lancet هذا اليوم
ويعلن أن إسبانيا بعيدة جدًا
عن ما يسمى بعقلية القطيع ،
الطريقة الوحيدة التي ستصل بها إلى هناك
تقول هذه الدراسة إذا كنت على استعداد لقبول
ما يسمونه الضمانات  العديد من الأضرار التي لحقت
بالعديد من الوفيات أكثر من
28000 بالفعل في هذا البلد بسبب
فيروس كورونا بين الآن
نشرت لانسيت تعليقًا مصاحبًا من
قبل اثنين من الفيروسات exp.  erts من
جنيف ، لذلك قال بشكل أساسي أن
عقلية القطيع ، مناعة القطيع غير قابلة
للتحقيق ، فلنعد سريعًا
إلى هذه الفاشيات في جميع أنحاء البلاد
بعد أن خرجوا من هذا
الإغلاق لمدة ثلاثة أشهر على الصعيد الوطني الذي يحاولون الآن
تحديث تحديث تتبع جهات الاتصال حتى
يتمكنوا من ذلك.  يمكن أن تدخل
وتقطع بعض المناطق جراحيًا ، لكن تلك المنطقة في
كاتالونيا شمال شرق إسبانيا التي
تحدثت فيها عن مائتي ألف شخص
في هذه المقاطعة محاصرون من قبل
ضباط الشرطة الذين يغلقون الطرق من الداخل والخارج
الآن والتي بدأت مع
عمال المزارع الموسميين حوالي 500 حالة هناك الآن
مع  تم حبس 200000 شخص في
شمال غرب إسبانيا على طول
المحيط الأطلسي في تلك القرى في غاليسيا ،
حيث يوجد أكثر من مائة
حالة هناك ولكن تم إغلاق 70.000 شخص ،
وهذا هو نوع الإجراءات التي
تتبعها السلطات الإقليمية الإسبانية الآن.
اتخذت الحكومة الوطنية الإسبانية
لمحاولة إغلاق هذا ومنع أي
تفشي متجدد على نطاق واسع
الفراغ والخوف في شوارع روما ، واحدة من أجمل مدن أوروبا بينما ينفتح الاتحاد الأوروبي على السفر بعد أن احتوت معظم الدول على جائحة فيروس كورونا ، لن يعود السائحون الأمريكيون في أي وقت قريبًا ، ويقول صاحب المطعم ، بيت سوزي ، إن هذا أمر آخر أثر كبير في أرباحه الضئيلة بالفعل ، نحن قلقون للغاية ، يقول إننا نعيش على هذا الحد ، ولا أعرف ما إذا كان هذا صحيحًا أم خطأ ، لكنني كنت أفضل أن يتم فتح الحدود لأننا في حالة توقف ، إنها ليست إيطاليا فقط تعد فرنسا واحدة من أكثر الوجهات شعبية للسياح الأمريكيين في أوروبا وفقًا لهيئة السياحة في البلاد ، حيث جاء حوالي أربعة ملايين ونصف المليون أمريكي إلى هنا في عام 2018 وأنفقوا ما يقرب من أربعة مليارات دولار في فرنسا ، معظمها في باريس ، حسبما قال رئيس هيئة السياحة في المدينة. CNN الأمريكية لنا مهمة جدًا لباريس من حيث السياحة فالأشخاص الأمريكيون ينفقون حوالي ملياري دولار في الواقع وهذا يمثل خسارة فادحة لباريس.  في الوقت الحالي ، لكن الاتحاد الأوروبي
قرر الاستمرار في حظر الولايات المتحدة.  المواطنون
من القدوم إلى الاتحاد الأوروبي
باستثناء الولايات المتحدة
من قائمة الدول التي سيسمح الاتحاد الأوروبي منها
للمسافرين بالعودة حيث
تكافح إدارة ترامب مع
ارتفاع حاد في حالات الإصابة بفيروس كورونا في
أجزاء من الولايات المتحدة بينما
يرفض الرئيس إجراءات الصحة العامة
مثل ارتداء الملابس.  قناع بينما يحرص الاتحاد الأوروبي
على تحفيز مسؤولي قطاع السياحة المتعثر
هنا في بروكسل وفي
الدول الأعضاء ، يقولون إن القارة
بحاجة إلى توخي الحذر عند فتح
آخر شيء تحتاجه أوروبا هو ارتفاع آخر
في إصابات فيروس كورونا وربما
إغلاق أوروبي آخر
لطالما قال مسؤولو الاتحاد إنهم
سيضعون الصحة العامة فوق
الدوافع الاقتصادية عند إعادة
اقتصاداتهم مرة أخرى للإسراع في السرعة ،
وأهم شيء هو حماية
حماية الصحة العامة في دوفر ،
فهذه هي الأولوية الأكثر أهمية بالنسبة
للاتحاد الأوروبي والدول الأعضاء فيه  هذا
يعني أن شوارع روما تبدأ
بالملء بالمطعم مرة أخرى
سيتعين على المديرين مثل النموذج Pete suti الانتظار
حتى وصول الولايات المتحدة.  سيطر على الوباء حتى يتمكن
الأمريكيون من إعادة فريد
بليتجن سي إن إن بروكسل